et soyez solidaires les
peintures et c'est normal concentration
maximale pour les joueurs d'où il ya
quelques minutes d'entrer sur leur
terrain pour affronter concarneau en 32e
de finale de la coupe de france cinq
divisions séparent le petit poucet de
l'équipe bretonne pensionnaire de
nationale une une fois sur le terrain
concarneau marque deux buts dans les 15
premières minutes dans une ambiance
électrique 2 0 ce sera le score à la mi
temps c'est très compliqué on a fait une
entame de match très compliquée j'ai
senti tendu par comme d'habitude mais ça
fait partie du sport maintenant moi
personnellement on va essayer de revient
à 2-1 on va voir comment ils vont réagir
au quart dolan on va s'accrocher à sa
prochaine une entame de match compliquée
qui ne décourage pas les 2000 supporters
présents au stade pour le premier 32e de
finale du club depuis 1940 un mois de ça
joue 90 minutes donc temps que le coup
de sifflet final il est pas il est pas
sifflé on peut toujours y croire après
je pense que deux fois être réaliste un
petit peu et je pense que concarneau
joue tranquillement bien sûr j'y crois
encore
c'est le hacker je suis et où une micro
bien sûr
serait rentré chez moi autour des
vestiaires pas de miracle ou ne
reviendra pas concarneau marque même un
troisième but par l'intermédiaire dit
dasa la 84e minute pour mettre fin à
l'épopée des yvelinois ce qu'en finale 3
[Applaudissements]
déçue déçue de déçus de la physionomie
du match parce qu'en première mi temps
je pense qu'on les a trop respectés et
après en deuxième on a été plus haut on
a montré qu'on avait un peu de qualité
mais bon c'est le football est comme ça
après cette parenthèse coupe de france
où devra replonger rapidement dans le
quotidien du championnat de r3 où il
occupe la dernière place prochain match
le dimanche 14 janvier sur le terrain de
choisy le roi